hello everyone and welcome back to the
TC EC season 17 super final in game 96
between lilica 0 and stockfish the super
final already ended but since the whole
magnus invitational and then the Nations
Cup started we didn't have a catch at
least draw some sort of a conclusion
from this whole super final thing so for
those of you who don't know what this is
well basically Lila and stocks which are
playing 100 chess games against each
other these are classical games and they
are playing prearranged opening so first
Lila will have a certain line with the
white pieces then stalkerish will have
that exact same line in the exact same
opening with the white pieces so so it's
fair and it's a lot more interesting for
us as we get to see a lot of a lot of
different openings so like I said this
is game 96 Lila with the white pieces
and Lila opens with E for now we have
East 6 the fringe defense by stockfish d
4 D 5 and a 5 the advance variation of
the French and now B 6 and this is the
last book move as of as of move three
now we don't have a completely new game
but we do have now a Lila's first move
basically so here
Lila goes for h4 we have c5 striking in
the center and now c3 as you would
usually do in the advanced French and
now there is one game in the database
for Knights the d7 was played but here
stalkerish goes for Knight to c6 and
already as of move 5 we have a
completely new game that's why I'm
saying that I do to the openings being
prearranged that we have new games
already as of move 5 so Knight to f3 we
push up the d7 a boat we went off you
just keep developing pieces Bishop to d3
and Queen to c7 now we have castles by
Lila and here starfish grabs on d4 we
have C captures on d4 but Lila doesn't
recapture but rather just Bishop to f4
develops a piece and defends the e5 pawn
and offers of course the c3 pawn so
first stockfish plays on a 6 we have a 3
by Lea in now stock which accepts the
pawn we have d characters on c3 Knight
captures on c3 and now be 5 so rook to
sea
one developing the rock putting it on
the same file as the Queen end it is the
only open file on the board and the
Queen to b6 now getting the Queen away
from the C file butter back the e3
attacking the Queen and Queen b8 now
again putting pressure on the e5 pawn
but rook to e1 and it's a very tricky
idea why the e5 pawn should not be
captured so now if Knight chapters on e5
which of course was not played in the
game do you see how white wins the game
on the spot all right it's a very sneaky
tactic so even feel free to pause the
video and try to figure it out while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
e-file needs to open up and for those of
you who just won't enjoy the show you
can start with Knight captures an e5 but
this is more precise just Knight
captures on b5 and that's it and it
doesn't matter what black place even if
you capture on f3 first with check
you're just gonna play Queen captures
and now that's that's all there is you
don't have a good reply of course if you
capture the knight in Bishop f4 check
just picks up the Queen so not not a lot
of fun in that and if you don't capture
the night well you don't have you don't
have a lot of good moves for example if
you continue development Bishop to b6
you get Bishop to d4 and again now you
cannot capture the night as the file has
opened up there's the threat of Bishop
character sin g7 and after the King goes
here just queen g4 and black will very
very quickly suffer a terrible fate for
example f6 you you need to block Queen
captures on g7 and you're gonna get well
a lot of a lot of ideas are possible
here such as you can go Knights the b6
attack the rook you can even go rook
captures and e6 is an idea and then
after Bishop characters you get Queen
captures on e6 and there are simply
simply too many threats for example if
let's say you try and defended the
seventh rank you you just lose the rook
there and if you try something like
let's say the Queen can't move the Queen
needs to keep an eye on the bishop here
so not it's basically you can't make a
move let's see if you try something like
night here I just worked the c7 you add
another attacker and that
just it you cannot capture because of
just Queen characters here and it's just
just a terrible position for example
characters you're gonna get Queen
captures 97 King g8 and now Bishop the
five coming over here so a lot of
madness here which which happens if the
if this is captured but there are there
are other ideas for example night
capture sandy five you don't have to
capture the night you can immediately
capture the pawn but it's still bad
because of Bishop to f4 now there's a
triple attack on the night you there's
no longer an opportunity to capture here
as there's the pin and if f6 just
defending damages again Knight captures
it captures and now just Bishop captures
an e5 attacking the Queen and after the
Queen moves most likely to a light
square as you don't wanna allow any
nasty discoveries so now again a lot of
move remove the win like rook c7 you can
go Bishop captures and g7 check pick up
the rook here so completely falling
apart and of course lastly but not
leastly after Knight captures here now
if you don't capture here or here you
can play something completely different
but it won't help you for example it
goes up to c6 you're gonna get night the
b6 and there is no there is no good way
to counter this for example Bishop
captures an f3 are gonna capture with
the Jeep on and you lose the rook here
because if the rook moves
of course rook the CH check just picks
up the Queen and that's it so now after
rook to e1 of course the five point is
not free for grabs but it's not at all
simple why it's not free for grabs so
congratulations to everyone who who
decided to check it out tonight the G to
e7 by stockfish and now b4 so expanding
on the Queen side not allowing black to
grab more space on the Queen side and
the white for the moment controls the C
file but it's down upon so we'll see is
is this upon sacrifice to justified or
not with h6 and now h5 grabbing even
more space on the King side with h4 h5
we have Queen that b7 now and Bishop to
f4 now the defending the pawn preparing
to shift the night / - over to D for
like a night here then I think oh here
we can trade of the these Knights
look the c8 black also grabs hold of the
open C file and now Queen to d2
connecting rooks we have rook the c7 and
now Bishop to g3 and I just are getting
getting the bishop to to a safer square
we have wrote the g8 now hoping to open
up the Kings side and now rook the c2
preparing to double up on the C file we
have looked back to see eight by
stockfish not not a lot of active moves
obviously a waiting move and now Knight
to e2 preparing to go to default to
trade some nights here and here Knights
the a7 offering up a roof trade with
knife the d4 and now rook captures and
c2 with Queen captures and c2 n down
tonight back to c6 and here Bishop to h7
now Lila wants to see if stock fish
stock fish is interested in repeating
the position we have rook to a trade and
now we're back to d3 and stock it
repeats rook to g8
we have Bishop to h7 and now road back
to h8 with now f4 of course Lila not
interested in a draw with the white
pieces even though down upon that the
position is it is very hard for black to
play so Knight captures and before we
have Knight captures and now Queen to c8
offering a trade of Queens and now rook
the c1 by Lila starfish trade we have
characters captures of course not with
the rook as the bishop would hang so
Bishop captures and c2 and now Knight to
c6 offering yet more trades and now Bush
of to f2 and here you can see that even
though both white and black have a
bishop pair black the bishop pair isn't
really doing anything so black really
needs to figure out how to how to go
about this although it's not easy with
the position being completely completely
closed and no bishops can can go
anywhere well whereas White's dark
square bishop slices nicely over here
and whites light square bishop slices
nicely over here so that's a good bishop
pair versus a bad bishop pair so Knight
back to b8 stockfish not interested in
trading off his only active piece and
Bishop to d3 now just improving the the
position of the bishop increasing the
activity where Bishop to e7 and now rook
the c7 as a black allowed so of course
King to d8 pushing the rule
back and now look the situ we have King
back the eh doctor says okay I'm down
with the draw here but Lila goes G for
and okay we have rook the g8 and now
came to g2 Lila starts improving the
position of the king
whereas storage doesn't really have
active moves so King to d8 and King to
g3 now we have rook to h8 and stop it
just keeps repeating moves and look the
C 1 we have rook the g8 and now Bishop
the G 1 now we have g6 and now stop
which needs to do something and H
captures and g6 we have F captures and
g6 in the now Bishop to e3 so still even
though you opened up this dark square
bishop a little bit you don't really
have any active ideas to go with that so
h5 by black but now just g5 again
closing off the dark square bishop and
the King will keep an eye on the undie
h-bond so King g8 we have looked the c7
again and now King to f7 not not
repeating King to d8 as then the root
can come to a 7 and it's not gonna be
very dangerous for the rook there so
king f7 instead in the now bush should
be back sorry bishop back to B 1 we have
looked the d8 now guarding the bishop so
maybe you can somehow activate the night
although it's incredibly difficult
because with the knight on d4 and the
rook here the c6 square is controlled by
Leela and with the c6 square law c6
square controlled by Leela you can never
go knight c6 or Bishop to c6 and the
stock which is just stuck here
so knight back to f3 and now we have d4
and it's a stock which gives back upon
but it's it's not at all clear what else
you would play you don't have a pawn
move you know you can't move any of your
pieces you can't it's it's just hard for
example if you try something like rook
to g8 if you repeat a route move then
Bishop the a7 comes and now you just
lose the game because you are attacking
the defender of the bishop here the
bishop has nowhere to go you still have
still have nothing even bishop c6 now
just captures the knight and then you
pick up the bishop and that's that's
just it the the bishop cannot go back
because then the knight is not the
and so it would be terrible so here
stock fish instead at the save save the
game for the moment goes d4 he gives up
a pawn Knight captures and before
Balilla and now rook to see it offers up
a rogue trade and here comes a rook the
b7 declining the trade we have worked
back to d8 you could go rook the c3
attacking the bishop but then the King
moves to to f2 and again you you will
have some problems here as the knight is
under attack and you cannot move the
knight as the bishop hangs
so instead after work - b7 we have
looked to d8 defending the bishop once
again and now Bishop to c4 so again Leo
just grabbing more space rook to e8
stockfish is doomed to repeat moves and
now King to have two starting to improve
the position of the king and here again
probably probably disgusted with the
position so to say stock goes for h4 we
have King to g2 by Leela and now rook
the see it starfish grabs hold of the
open sea file and now Bishop to f2 i
just goes after the h4 pawn but there is
no rush in capturing it since you can
always capture it there's no way white
can prevent that black can prevent that
so bishop - I ate and now look the b6
now putting pressure on the e6 pawn so
bishop has to go back with the ship to
DS Bishop to d7 and now comes King to H
do although you could you could capture
the pawn right away but Leela decides
for King to h2 and here we have a 5 so
trying to break up in the position on
the other side activate the bishop pair
this way okay B captures on e5
and now Bishop to d8 attacking the rook
and you're gonna recapture on e5 later
on so look the b7 in out Bishop captures
on a5 we have Knight captures on b5 and
now King to g8 we have Knight to d6 now
attacking the rook and rook the f8 going
after idea for pawn and the Bishop to e3
now we have Bishop to c6 offering a
trade and here leo says no problem we
have characters captures in the now
Knight back to e4 so stock Fischer was
able to activate the pieces but it cost
him a lot of material since when this
whole
operation started stockbridge was up
upon but now after rupee f7 and the
trade of rooks that happened to captures
captures we have Bishop to F do and now
this point is a goner as well so from
being up upon to being down to points
that's what it took to save the position
and somewhat activate the piece pieces
so 97 but now Bishop captures on h4 and
this is of course now winning in a game
between Leo and stockfish when either
illegal or stock fishes is up two points
it's pretty much a done deal and it's
pretty much a matter of just converting
the advantage of two pawns which is not
a problem for an engine but well I will
show it as it is as it is an interesting
endgame so 95 going after the pawn here
Bishop g3 defending in our Bishop the c7
our stock fish will have to stall for as
long as possible we have Bishop a5 kingi
for now and King to e7 and okay Buster
back to f2 with King to d7 King to f3
and now came to c6 with Bishop to e3 in
now Bishop the c3 just seeing if if
white is maybe interested in giving up a
night for a bishop allele I'm not
interested just Bishop the c1 and now
Bishop to d4 we have King te to the
bishop now nicely defends the both of
these pawns that are are perhaps a
vulnerable to attacks so better back to
c5 and now King to d3 slowly but surely
really improves the position of the King
Bishop f8 and now King to c4 we have
Knight b6 check and now King to c3
Bishop to e7 and now King to d3 we have
Knight to d5 and now King to c4 so
improving the position even more if the
a pawn starts marching up the board
that's that's pretty much it
we have Bishop to d8 and now Knight to
f6 hoping to trade off a pair of nights
so nice the b6 check King to b3 and now
Knight the a8 again just waiting to see
how Leela will try to progress we have
Bishop to d2 and now Bishop to b6
with a 4 starting to push the past pawn
and now Knight the c7 so you don't want
to over push it
just because you can but you could play
it but little Lila decides to improve
the position even further King to see
for an out brush it back to a seven with
King to d3 now and the bishop back to c5
Knight to e4 now going after the bishop
and the bishop back to f8 we have King
to c4 and now Bishop to e3 and not
allowing the King to cross using this
diagonal with Knight to c3 and now
Knight to the a6 we have Bishop to e3
and now Bishop to b4 so stockfish
created a barrier here at the two points
controlled the three points nicely on
the King side and the King into pieces
control the past a pawn so can he
perhaps hold this
well nights to eat you bye Leela and now
Bishop the e1 with Knights to d4 with
trick King to d7 in the now Knight to b3
so slowly but surely making progress
threatening unite to c5 check to
exchange the night here so King to c6
and now a5 finally we have Bishop the g3
now putting pressure on the pawn here
but it's not a problem 90 d4 check we
have King to d7 and now comes in Bishop
to d2
and here it's a problem for black guys
what do you what do you do the king b5
is coming and if you try something like
Bishop to f2 to try and keep an eye on
the night
then you get a knight the c2 and after
the bishop moves yes you grab hold of
this diagonal but now it's Bishop to e3
trying to trade over the bishops and
after the bishop moves now again King b8
and the King finally infiltrates the
position and the da pond will Queen so
instead Lila try the Bishop - sorry it's
not astride Bishop - H - but now it's
fairly simple when you have a bishop on
the edge of the board then you just go
Knight to e2
and now the knight controls all of the
squares that the bishop can use to get
back into the game so now it's fairly
simple you will just March your King
over here and pick up the Bishop and
that's it and that's exactly what what
happened in the game we have king c6
Bishop e3 now Knight to c7 with Bishop
to c1 and Knight to d5 with Bishop to d2
now the
the bishop also controls the movements
of the night while this knife controls
the movements of the bishop Knights the
East 7 in now King to d3 we have King
Tubby 7 and now came to e4 so slowly but
surely the King makes his way to the
King side night of 5 and now King to f3
we have night the h4 check now you first
kick away the night King g4 Knight has
to go back and now keep the h3 and there
is no defense against King captures
Bishop so Bishop the g1 and now Knight
captures on g1
we have Knight the d4 and now of course
like in every other game Leo a place
whenever Leela goes up material she
immediately starts giving material back
and here Leela goes f5 and it's very
interesting point is you free the DF 4
square with the night because if either
of the pawn captures then you've created
a passed pawn and wow those those were
some bad arrows and of course if the
knight captures then 92 and you've free
DF 4 square for the knight so when the
night comes to a 4 you can easily
eliminate the g6 or the e6 pawn create a
passed pawn and just win the game so
after f5 with each captures on f5
instead of Knight captures as you just
seen what happens here and it's always
like this with Levi I find that this
this gif perfectly illustrates Leila's
behavior after after feeds off material
like and the the money here being the
material so there we have it but yeah I
thought you might enjoy that reference
so Bishop to e3 attacking the knight we
have Knight goes back to e 6 and now
just Knights that e 2 with f4 now giving
up some material back says that that's
that there's no point in playing this
game any longer but engines do play it
out until the evaluation by both engine
is like more than +10 or something like
that so Knight captures and g5 check
with King to g4 and now tonight back to
f7 we have Knight characters in g6 and
here King to a6 finally going after that
pawn but King f5 and here doctors just
played Knight captures on 85 to sort of
try and be funny I guess
and it was also in this position that
stock we should resign
game or rather both engines agreed that
the game is with absolutely winning for
white so Lila did not even capture the
night and this is it a hundred ten nine
moves and water game it was so basically
after the interesting part which is like
the first thirty moves let's say up to
this point yeah alright already here
let's say haha okay maybe okay up up to
this point black is black is basically
completely lost
there's no way to play there's no way to
get the pieces into the game whites
control of the c6 square completely
eliminates any play from black the
bishops are useless the King cannot
enter the game as the C file belongs to
the white rook and there is no way for
this rook to enter the game so basically
the game is over but of course the
engines need to play it out but I
thought this was a very interesting game
so I decided to show this one it was
game 96 so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marcus
wanna open era cogniat a Frank Olson Tom
Murphy and Michael Truesdale for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the Morphy saga and well
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day